Пів на дев’яту ранку.
Дзвін у храмах Московського патріархату.
Через 20 хвилин – у храмах Київського.
У всіх православних церквах міста Ніжин, а їх тут 15,
розпочинається недільна служба.
У чотирьох храмах Київського патріархату моляться українською…
- За створення в Україні єдиної православної помісної церкви
Господу помолимось.
В 11-ти церквах московського патріархату
возносять молитву старослов’янською.
Тут, на відміну від київського патріархату,
єдину помісну українську православну церкву
в молитвах наразі не згадують.
Не визнають тут і українських святих, канонізованих київським патріархатом.
- Ікона преподобного святого Меркурія Бригинського.
Це святий канонізований Українською православною церквою КП.
Отець Михаїл служить у храмі  Святої Покрови з 1995 року.
Він приїхав у Ніжин із Західної України.
За 23 роки священник пережив усяке:
від відвертої ворожнечі з боку московського патріархату
до більш-менш мирного співіснування.
На тлі дискусії щодо надання томоса Україні в Ніжині,
як неофіційно розповіли DW місцеві священики,
виникли фактично два табори і в обох патріархатах.
Одні проти об'єднання, інші чекають на автокефалію.
- Ну я для себе це називаю "холодною війною ".
Коли мирно, здавалося б, так.
Але є  священики…Не хочеться говорити погано,
але які там поза спиною проклинають.
Як в Україні казали: "Крутять дулі за спиною ".
Коли буде томос, дуже багато з московського патріархату потягнуться
і забудуться вся ті негаразди.
Парафіяни в Ніжині, як і священики:
жодних публічних конфліктів через релігію.
Утім, багато хто обіцяє залишатися вірним своєму патріархату.
- За Московський я.
Тому що все… ну я навіть не знаю...
З давніх-давен усе було російською мовою, всі проповіді.
- Там на старослов’янській. Я мало що розумію.
А тут все зрозуміло. Українською мовою.
- Ми виросли і батьки наші, і ми, і всі в православії.
Яке це може бути українська?
- За Київський патріархат. За Україну. Тільки, тільки!
У великі свята, як на Великдень,
різниця між патріархатами для незатятих парафія
і зовсім не помітна. Священники усіх церков
святять паски кожному, хто прийде.
Це найбільше до вподоби городянам.
- Я ходжу і в київський, і московський.
Я йду не в церкву, а до Господа Бога
і йому поклоняюся.
- Якщо ми частину грошей віддавали Росії
нібито за їхнє православ'я, що вони нас покривають,
то ця частина грошей залишиться повністю в нас.
Утім, чи безболісно мине надання томоса Україні,
в Ніжині не впевнені навіть священники.
Аби православні храми тут, у Ніжині,
і далі мирно співіснували, священнослужителі
радять правоохоронцям посилити охорону
в першу чергу храмів московського патріархату,
аби запобігти провокаціям із боку радикалів.
Радикалізм із обох боків найбільше непокоїть отця Михаїла.
Він сподівається на швидке надання томоса,
аби і парафіянам, і священикам було зрозуміло,
як діяти далі. Найменше він би хотів повернення в 90-ті роки,
коли, за словами священника, йому приносили
квитки на потяг і казали забратися
разом зі своїм Київським патріархатом із Ніжина.